The Joe Rogan experience.
Or communities, it's all over the place on YouTube.
But because of this current pandemic,
they feel like there's this heightened sense of responsibility. They have to,
to control the narrative. And that's, that's very disturbing to me.
And what's even more disturbing to me is how people,
when they agree with that narrative, don't understand where this all goes.
And they're, they're agreeing with that censorship. They're like, yes,
censor those people get rid of those voices, deep platform,
people that I disagree with, and they don't understand where this goes.
It's like where people are saying the people that have, uh,
that have been vaccinated that want a vaccine passport. Yes,
we should have a vaccine passport. I've been vaccinated. That's not going to,
it's only going to help me. I did my part.
I took one for the team and I went out and got vaccinated to be a good citizen.
Those people who didn't them, we should have a vaccine Pentagon,
but here's the problem with it. The vaccine passport, it doesn't end there.
It's going to keep going.
And it's going to lead to some sort of a social system.
You're going to have a social credit system,
similar to what they have happened in our lifetime. A hundred percent,
you're saying a hundred percent, a hundred percent. It can happen. Or, you know,
100% can happen in our lifetime because people will step with it.
They will go as long as it benefits them.
And as long as it aligns with their ideology,
they will ignore the dangers of a social credit system.
And they will embrace it. Yeah. If I would never thought people would be look,
six months ago, the white house was saying,
there's no way we would ever use some sort of a vaccine mandate.
Kamala said I would never take the vaccine. So did buy it.
Both of them said that. Yeah, they both did. But then once they got into office,
six months ago, they said we would never use a mandate.
We would never try to force businesses or people to be vaccinated.
Now they are saying that now they want you to do that.
Did you see that video where they're talking about Biden is talking about the
hurricane? No, no. Have you seen that? Jamie here?
I'll say the one where the kids laughing here,
I'll send you this one because this is the funniest one, because these,
these guys were watching them say this.
And as these guys are watching them say this, uh, it's just funny here.
I'm gonna send you this. Hold on one second. It's hurricane he's.
He's telling them they should get vaccinated before the hurricane comes. It's a,
it's obviously a joke, right? No, it's not a joke. He's been,
he's being dead serious, but you got to watch this. I just said to you,
Jamie was watching. We'll watch it on the screen.
We'll have a nice laugh because it's not that you shouldn't get vaccinated.
That's not what I'm saying. It's just like the narrative is so it's so
overwhelming that it applies to everything. Now it applies to the hurricane.
Play this, give me some.
Hurricanes often strikes like Florida or the Gulf coast or into
Texas of vital.
Part of preparing for hurricane season is to get vaccinated. Now,
everything is more complicated.
If you're not vaccinated in a hurricane or natural disaster hits.
Got a hill. Does that make any sense? Okay.
So, so people are just stepping in line saying,
don't take the vaccine. That's not what you're saying.
I think a lot of people should take the vaccine. Okay.
So I got a story for you here from my personal. And my dad is 79 years old.
Okay. A conversation came about the vaccine. He said, are you taking it? I said,
I'm not taking it. I was in the army and the army,
the first day of going into the army. They give you 11 air shots.
When you go in and you just go through, literally,
you want 11 shots of lemon shots in one day back to back to back. And you say,
don't move. If you move a little bit, get a scar. I mean,
I'll never forget this. I was 18 years old. Sure.
I've had plenty of vaccine in myself. It's probably why I'm a little bit off.
But so my dad, okay. He says, should I get the vaccine?
I said that it's up to you. What do you want to do? So as pat, you know,
I'm 77 years old. I said that if you're 79, do what you want to do.
So I want to get the vaccines. They went and got the vaccine. Great.
I didn't get the vaccine. I got COVID. So he ends up getting the vaccine.
And two weeks ago, he just got his negative back from COVID.
He got positive and he got pneumonia.
My dad had 79 and he is okay, he's done. He squared away.
He has nothing to worry about today.
Would it have been different if he didn't have the vaccine? I don't know.
It's like it would have most likely it would have been.
So I would've been working made sense that he took the vaccine and the benefit
of a friend of mine younger than in my 20 years in great shape.
Didn't have to shout it. Didn't take the shot. He got vaccine,
he got COVID and had pneumonia was in a hospital for four weeks.
Literally he was hospitalized. Right? Uh, for myself, I didn't take the vaccine.
There's a few reasons why I haven't taken a vaccine yet. A smile.
One reason why I'm taking the vaccine yet.
But the biggest challenge for me is the conversation of being forced to take
the vaccine. So Nicki Minaj,
I'm sure you kind of following the story with what's going on with Nicki Minaj,
cousins, testicles, cousins, testicles, and Trinidad, and people are saying,
are you kidding me about these testicles?
So what did these testicles are just massive or something happened to them?
Or it was because of a, the vaccine let's set that aside with the testicles.
I've never heard of testicles swelling. I haven't, I've heard of other things,
but not because of the vaccine. Yes. So, okay. So that's that part. All right.
So she goes up, then she says, I don't want to take it on her life, Joe,
you got to listen to her life.
It's so funny because she puts the camera and the javelin set the ceiling.
You're never just talking. It's the light. Right? And she says,
let me get this straight because, uh,
she put it out on Twitter that I got a call from the white house to go and have
a meeting at the white house with, uh, the, the health secretary.
And, uh, what do you call it? What? Fowchee? Right. Meeting with Fowchee.
And she said, I would like to come, but I would like it to be alive. Uh,
instead of me traveling, I'd much rather not travelers to alive and to say,
yeah, we don't mind doing a live. We just don't want it to be recorded.
She says, no,
I want it to be recorded because I want my audience to see whether this is,
you know, some honest with the audience. They say, well, let us think about it.
She has her PR rep on it and our agent on the call.
So it's not like she's by herself. Then a white house comes back and says, no,
we never told you that you're going to be doing this live. Right.
Cause she tweeted us and I got a call from white house and she says,
why can't I have the choice to not do it? Why can't I not have the choice,
the biggest contradiction for do the vaccine. I don't want to take the vaccine.
They're forcing her to do it. And you know,
you heard a couple of the folks from, uh,
I don't know what it was when they came out. And they said,
who was the lady that we were talking about? She said,
I got 2 million followers, girl. I'm not at your level with, you know,
22 million followers on Twitter. You know, you, you can do better, girl.
You ought to be shamed yourself for doing this because now people are not taking
a vaccine. Who's a joy, uh, what's her name? Oh, Joanne Reed.
I, yeah, I, I think that's what was in. So she comes back and she says,
just because I don't want to do it. I don't want to do it.
So why do I have to do it?
I may end up doing it because I have to go on tour and I have to do this part.
But if you're going to a point, Joe, yourself,
while you're talking about 100%, this is going to happen in our generation.
Then I ask you, are you okay with.
That? Didn't say 100%. It's going to happen. I said, 100%.
It could happen that we have a social credit score in this
country. The same people that are accepting of a vaccine passport.
My position is I do not believe once the government has the ability to control
your movement, what you do. And when you do it,
if they can put limitations on your freedom. And that,
that is what it is that it makes it easier to control people. Once they do that.
I do not believe they're going to leave it at a vaccine passport.
I agree with you. I think they're going to expand it.
And I think the next logical move is some sort of a social credit
score. And you will look at a bunch of things. Have you paid your taxes?
Have you, are you in debt? Do you owe money on your credit cards?
Are you in default of loans? Um, have you been vaccinated?
Have you, have you voted and all those things who you voted for? Well,
that would be problematic,
but all those things could be designed into a
social credit program where you,
you could see in a person who has poor social credit,
a person who's been to jail for armed robbery,
a person who owes taxes,
that person would have a lower credit score and they wouldn't be allowed into
certain buildings. Why.
Is this a bad thing?
Because it's control.
It's having the ability to tell people what they can and can't do. However,
the government, if you're a free person, I mean, you've made mistakes or you're,
you know, you're trying to do better in your life,
but you've had some horrible scenarios in your, in your past.
You're,
you're supposed to be free to try to navigate and do better in your life.
If you're restricted and very clearly re restricted by the,
a set of parameters,
that's decided by other people that doesn't have to do with the law. Like,
it's not like you need to be locked up because you're a criminal. You,
you have a social credit score. Like they're implementing in China.
What it does is it keeps people scared and it keeps people in line.
And it's a fantastic way to control the population.
And that's what it's used for. Should we do something about it?
I think talking about is a good thing. I think talking about it,
like we're talking about allowing people to recognize this is something that
could potentially happen.
You think there's a vaccine passport just six months ago was conspiracy theory,
nonsense. Like people were like, what the you talking about?
You're not going to have a vaccine passport.
No one was no one was accepting the fact that this was real.
This was the stuff that Alex Jones talked about.
But now it's a real thing in New York. Yeah. It's a real it's LA now. Oh yeah.
They just announced it three days right after Newsome. Right? The next day.
That's right. The next thing,
how clever watch the entire episode for free, only on Spotify.